if we take an open jar into space to
outer space and close it once up there
by filling it with the vacuum of space
what would happen if we bring it to the
earth level atmosphere and even to the
international space it would be the best
vacuum we would have ever encountered on
earth ever really yes we can drink that
Kim's as good as space vacuum really
yeah last I checked we can't do it
there's somebody last week pulled one
off we can't we can't we can't have it
as much as space is just like so far
better vacuum than anything we've been
able to create in our lives so why don't
we always bring back the terms of that
dinner I do have a new business right
there sell jars of the best vacuum
you've ever seen but I like the way the
question was worded think that where the
vacuum gets inside the jar what happens
is the air inside the jar escapes yeah
by the way once you put the vacuum in it
yeah and then you bring it back to earth
what what will happen is the inner
surface of the glass and presumably a
metal lid will out gas into that volume
their gas is dissolved on the surfaces
of all solid objects uh-huh and it just
stays there it's molecules that are just
stuck in the jaggedy surface of every of
every solid object if you now evacuate
the center of that jar the it dislodges
those gas molecules and so it'll then
put some kind of gas pressure back in if
you're ever trying to create a perfect
vacuum yeah first vacuum it out then you
heat the sides of the container that
releases the gas that's attached then
vacuum it out again what would you bring
into space to bring back in back well
something that has a really really
smooth surface with hardly any gases
attached to it more than more smooth
than glass oh yeah oh yeah so glass yeah
way more so maybe you could pre-heat it
before you did this and bring like Jon
Hamm just somebody who's super smooth
yeah all right what else you got
here's a question
hey Neil oh by the way you might ask
yeah if quote-unquote nature abhors a
vacuum which of course it doesn't cuz
most of the universe is vacuum mm-hm how
come over Earth's atmosphere doesn't
just rush out into the vacuum of space
it's true hey do you mind effin it yeah
because Earth has gravity and the ground
keeps the Vanya's fear separate from the
rest of the vacuum of space that's all
okay all right here's the question I
just discovered did I just say that no
so wait no a vacuum I should answer that
completely differently yeah so a vacuum
on earth mm-hmm we think of nature
pouring it because air wants to get
inside the vacuum air ones can go into
the bed air once it goes because you're
in a place where this air pressure that
wants to get inside as you get higher up
in the atmosphere the air pressure gets
less and less and less and less and less
because it's less the air above it
pressing down what do you have less and
less and less and less and less the air
another one and do anything it's got no
forces there's no air pressure to make
it one it's just gonna float away okay
so all right miss fear goes out
thousands of miles getting average so
thinner as it gets out there and so it's
it's not that earth is holding the
atmosphere down although it is it's that
the air pressure out there has no urge
to go anywhere other than just staying
right where it is right yeah okay